[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
émission audition au public l'émission
politique commune lcp et public sénat
tous les lundis soir en direct du des
studios du figaro en partenariat avec le
figaro et la fp notre invité ce soir et
fabien roussel bonsoir monsieur bonsoir
vous êtes le numéro un du parti
communiste français secrétaire nationale
et députée du nord si vous permettez je
vais rappeler le découpage les règles de
l'émission qui vous accueille pour une
heure d'abord les questions d'actualité
avec justement les représentants de nos
deux partenaires sophie de ravinel vance
mars voirie pour le figaro djilalli
bekkar pour l' afp l'agencé
france-presse bonsoir battisti vous
opposeront les premiers vous poseront
les premières questions dans un instant
puis deux parlementaires viendront comme
c'est la règle si vous interrogez pierre
henri dumont députée l ère du pas de
calais vous connaissez bien j'imagine
n'est pas loin du nord et martin
lévriers sénateurs la république en
marche des yvelines et vous serez enfin
interpellé et interrogé par brigitte
boucher pour la chaîne lcp et au
rayonnement cini pour public sénat c'est
parti fabien roussel
évidemment l'actualité on le sait bien
aujourd'hui ce sont les suites des
manifestations violentes qui ont eu lieu
en particulier samedi sur les champs
elysées à paris des images tout à fait
spectaculaire on a des gens qui ne
savent pas pourquoi ils sont dehors à
part pour détruire ce sont les mots il y
à quelques instants d'emmanuel macron à
l'elysée qui reçoit une cinquantaine
d'intellectuels
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
caractérisation de ceux qui ont
manifesté et détruit et saccagé samedi à
paris il y a surtout en france depuis 18
semaines
mais au delà depuis de nombreux mois
beaucoup de français qui réclament de
pouvoir vivre dignement pouvoir d'achat
justice fiscale ces questions sont au
coeur du débat
depuis 18 semaines il y à une infime
minorité de casseurs d'homme violent qui
viennent dans les manifestations
pourrir les manifestations et nous même
quand nous en organisons et quand nous
participons manifestations comme celle
du premier mais on a vu aussi que ces
manifestations pouvait être pollué par 7
c ces casseurs infime minorité par honda
vient de s'allumer une personne engagée
dans ces violences a précisé ce matin
lors en 1e 10000 c'est une infime
minorité
sur les trente mille manifestants
recensés non non non non c'est bon ou
non ces jeux je sais bien que c'est pas
vrai je les mets en cause mais c'est pas
la réalité il ya une stratégie qui est
faite par le ministère le ministre de
l'intérieur dans la chaîne de
commandement qui est d'ailleurs mise en
cause puisque le ministère de
l'intérieur n'a pas su faire en sorte
que ces manifestations se déroulent dans
la sécurité
mais ils ont fait un choix depuis 18 ans
le ministère gouvernement a fait un
choix c'est la stratégie de la nasse de
l'encerclement c'est à dire que il
il laisse les manifestants se
rassemblent et en a lieu les
champs-elysées la place de la république
ils ferment toutes les issues et ensuite
ça cartonne
il ya les bombes de désencerclement les
bombes lacrymogènes et elles bd etc
le groupe armé parmi eux et qui mène la
cia quand il y a plusieurs milliers de
manifestants sur les champs-elysées
plusieurs milliers de manifestants place
de la république ou ailleurs il y à une
infime minorité de casseurs et il y a
des gens qui veulent manifester il se
trouve que quand ils se trouvent dans
ces conditions d'encerclement avec les
grenades de désencerclement et bien là
c'est la pagaille
ça part dans tous les sens on en a connu
on a eu des témoignages de gens qui
étaient dans ces manifestations qui
voulaient partir au moment où ça
canardait qui ne pouvait pas partir on
ne distinguait clairement que le nôtre
que ce que nous nous disons assez que
depuis quatre ans depuis les lois elles
comrie et les grandes manifestations
contre les lois elles conneries nous
avons vu
ces casseurs venir dans les
manifestations la police si elle ne les
a pas encore identifié si elle ne les a
pas encore interpellées condamné pour
les interdire de manifestations sont
alors ils sont elles n'existent pas en
tant que tel en tant qu'entité est ce
que vous pensez qu'il ya une mise en
scène volontaire de la violence par le
gouvernement par les autorités alors
écoutez on peut s'interroger on peut
s'interroger pourquoi il y à ces
dysfonctionnements
est ce que le préfet est incompétent
mais celui qu'ils vont nommer à la place
messieurs l'allemand préfet d'occitanie
a pas fait preuve de meilleurs résultats
vu ce qui se passe à bordeaux et
d'ailleurs ça fait partie il a la
réputation d'être assez ferme
ah oui c'est plutôt ce que j'entends et
sa fermeté a pu conduire aussi à de
l'escalator
moi je parle d'une forme d' escalade de
la violence qui peut se produire parce
qu'il ya une mauvaise évolution ne
mauvaise gestion de la sécurité
deux des manifestants volontaires cette
gestion ou incompétent il est ce qu'il
ya de volontaires dans le gouvernement
c'est d'apporter une réponse sécuritaire
que l'on ait toutes les semaines des
images de violence et de ne pas apporter
de réponse aux questions sociales au
pouvoir d'achat aux salaires et aux
retraites c'est ça qui est posé comme
question si la droite veut que ça c'est
ce qu'ils répondent aux questions le
pouvoir d'achat que posent les français
c'est ça pendant que ça manifesté ce
samedi nous étions dans le bureau du
premier ministre avec une délégation du
parti communiste français pour dire
qu'il y avait urgence a répondu à mes
propositions nos propositions on va en
parler après mais nous nous lui avons
dit d'abord il ya une urgence parce que
ça ne le pays va exploser explose de
colère je ne la justifie pas la violence
je la condamne monsieur mais je remercie
également de 2,2 g des jo ils veulent
manifester pacifiquement on valérie ne
peuvent plus le gouvernement a annoncé
donc des mesures sécuritaires
supplémentaires manifestation interdite
dans plusieurs quartiers de france où
l'on pense qu'il ya des
man ultras qui s'y mêlent augmentation
de 100 euros de la conterie la
contravention pour participation à
manifestation illégale l'utilisation de
drones réhabilitation d'une certaine
manière des ailes bds que c'est devenu
indispensable
est ce que c'est ce que veulent les
français aujourd'hui ou est ce que c'est
un tour de vis inutile d'abord ce que
veulent les français c'est qu'on
augmente leur pouvoir d'achat qu'ils
vivent dignement
mais c'est ça quand même le problème la
deuxième chose sur la sécurité sur les
plages de même chose s'est désolé
monsieur a précisé mme henry maillot
rose et en donner l'impression aux
pommes pour certains français quand même
d'un chaos et d'une impuissance à
maintenir l'ordre public d'ailleurs quoi
ils sont connus les black blocks un
chaos organisé e vous en livre sont
connus pourquoi je pose la question je
ne les ai pas la réponse mais je pose la
question gouvernement pourquoi ne sont
ils pas arrêté en amont pourquoi depuis
quatre ans qu'il sème la pagaille
il n'y a eu aucune décision de justice
ou dit lundi à sars-et-rosières musique
non non non non et s'il ya eu des
décisions de l'énergie sans pourquoi
elles ne sont pas arrêtées
la loi anti casseurs ne prévoit pas ça
elle prévoit de permettre un préfet sur
une simple décision administrative
d'interdire un manifestant de manifester
sur une simple décision administrative
c'est pas une décision de justice est
plus grave
si demain on a un gouvernement
autoritaire et celui là déjà un petit
peu les traits autoritaires et fils
dessine-moi les communistes cd violent
je demande au préfet d'empêcher les
communistes de manifester allez on va
aller on sait quoi tu sais c'est quoi
cette loi il y a aujourd'hui par contre
dans la loi la possibilité pour la
justice d'interdire de manifestation des
hommes des femmes qui ont eu des
comportements violents ça fait dix-huit
semaines que ça dure
ils n'ont pas été capables nos
renseignements généraux darin aux
policiers d'arrêter ceux qui cassent et
d'avoit de prononcer des décisions de
justice pour leur interdire de
manifester à cela expressément en
revanche j'en connais qui ont manifesté
et qui se sont retrouvés embarqués j'en
connais compris dans le nord qui ont
fait pour un feu de palettes sur un
rond-point sont aujourd'hui interdits
interdit de manifester
c'est pas juste alors
exemple ça permet justement de mieux
cibler les casseurs les drones qu'est ce
que vous en pensez l'utiliseront mais
s'ils peuvent balancer tous les drones
du monde qu'ils veulent pour surveiller
les manifestants on n'a pas besoin de
surveillance on n'a pas besoin de bâton
de matraque on a besoin de manger et des
fins de mois
pour les français la réponse de ce
gouvernement allait non seulement
sécuritaire mais lorsque j'entends dans
le premier ministre est qu'il va
augmenter d'un cran la sécurité la
répression il va dire il a dit aux
policiers
aller au contact maintenant et que va
répondre que vont répondre à dire que
vont répondre les c'est à dire ne pas
rester à distance larmes ok aller au
contact et on fasse peur mais en face on
va voir qui ont façonné les pacifistes
ils vont pas être là en face on va voir
qui donc on va voir les ultra violents
qui vont aller au contact aussi savent
aller jusqu'où il va y avoir semblé
responsabilités la france est au bord de
la guerre civile au bord de la guerre
sont allés au beau mais là on va c'est
l'escaladé de la violence dans des
nuances de gouvernement c'est pas que
organise le gouvernement c'est qu'il y à
un affrontement qui s'organise entre des
ultra-violents et que les vols paris
veulent qu'ils veulent eux ils l'ont ils
le disent d'ailleurs sur leur facebook
leur message on veut s'attaquer aux
symboles de la république aux symboles
de l'état
c'est inadmissible mais bien sûr mais je
vous dis les manifestations du 1er mai
nous pénalise de la même manière les
organisations syndicales ont interposés
l'exorde mention ça c'est exactement ce
que dit monsieur frédéric lordon
monsieur frédéric lordon qui est
économiste et qui est un proche de
françois ruffin
est-ce que vous condamnez ce type de
propos qui en appelle à l'insurrection
aujourd'hui jeanne à chapelle par
l'insurrection
j'appelle à ce que le gouvernement
apporte des réponses en politique on
doit apporter des réponses politiques
aux problèmes qui se passe dans notre
pays ce qui passe bien ils sont
nécessaires aujourd'hui on aujourd'hui
c'est un climat de violence qui se
développent et y compris le gouvernement
a décidé d'augmenter de pousser d'un
cran la répression une escalade de
violence final c'est de savoir comment
vous réagissez au fait qu' edouard
philippe prévoit dans son arsenal de
mesures de pouvoir poursuivre des
personnes qui appellent à la violence
qu'ils appellent éventuellement
justement s'attaquer à des institutions
puisque vous disiez que c'était le cas
de certains quand il y adhérer quand il
ya des hommes qui affichent leur
objectif d'aller à la casse y compris
des avec d'aller à l'acadie drouelle
avec kas d'y aller pour casser tel lieu
et c'est bien sûr qu'il faut créer les
conditions de s'affaisser que que ça ne
se passe pas enfin la fois je suis un
responsable politique révolutionnaire je
suis pour que ça change profondément
dans notre pays
ce système capitaliste est à bout de
souffle n'est pas le seul à le dire
d'ailleurs
on doit pouvoir faire ça sans violence
dans le calme et dans un rapport
démocratique normal vous dites nous
sommes au bord de la guerre civile est
ce que dans ces conditions vous appelez
à ce que on cesse ces manifestations ou
es ce que vous avez vous appelé à la
poursuite jugement non j'appelle à ce
que l'on n'ait le droit de manifester
quand on veut manifester pacifiquement
en famille avec les enfants sur les
épaules
comment on le fait comme j'ai pu le
faire parce qu'aujourd'hui on y lit à un
climat qui est créé et qu'on ne peut
même plus manifester en famille dans la
sécurité
je réclame ce droit là c'est un droit
constitutionnel fait aujourd'hui la
preuve de son incapacité à faire
respecter ce droit qui est celui de
manifester et dans notre pays qui est au
bord du gouffre parce que les français
n'en peuvent plus de ne pas pouvoir
vivre dignement des vins et bien et si
les gens doivent aller manifester toutes
les semaines et nous avec pour réclamer
ce droit de pouvoir vivre dignement et
bien nous continuerons le grand débat on
va parler on va passer aux grands débats
pardon fabien roussel puisque nous
sommes dans dans cette fin dans cet
épilogue d'un processus qui a été lancé
le 15 janvier par emmanuel
tron est ce que vous estimez qu emmanuel
macron doit accélérer dans la réponse
qu'il doit donner maintenant termes de
mesures de décision compte tenu de ce
qui s'est passé samedi
ou est-ce qu'il faut mieux qu'ils
prennent le temps d'analyser toutes les
remontées et me havrais fin avril de
faire valoir ses cds si tant est qu'il
faut qu'ils accélèrent wii garde son
rythme et ses serres qui s'éclaire qui
n'a intérêt à accélérer à passer la
démultipliée faut qu'ils changent de
braquet parce que là sinon la semaine
prochaine manif le violence qu'on s'en
sort plus j'ai vu le premier ministre
donc je voulais dit samedi et le
calendrier qu'il nous a présentée n'est
pas là pour nous rassurer il dit deux
choses
il dit que jusque mi avril fin avril en
dépouillons poursuit le débat à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat
les grandes régions etc après cela va
s'ouvrir un processus pour commencer à
discuter des éléments de réponse qui
pourrait être apportée et on va les
mettre
donnez pas ce que l'on va on atterrit
fin avril quand même non
je vous donne l'information que vous été
repoussée et donc on va mettre il
propose de mettre en débat dans le pays
les éléments de réponse qui pourrait
être apporté assez démocratique et d'une
manière avec est donc le deuxième la
deuxième chose qu'il dit et on va
demander aux français de choisir quel
bras ils veulent qu'on leur coupe pour
pour soigner l'autre parce que en gros
ça va être vous voulez ça on peut le
faire mais qu'est ce qu'on enlève de
l'autre côté vous voulez plus vous
disposiez bi quelles sont les dépenses
qu'elles sont les économies que l'on
fait ailleurs voulait qu'on augmente de
retraite où est ce qu'on enlève des
soigneurs ça va être ça et vous voulez
qu'on améliore au débat il ouvre à
démolir le
on n'a pas parlé à mon avis là dessus
n'ont pas atterri
mais faut qu'ils atterrissent je vous
parle je suis la meilleure de sentiments
pour moi le sentiment qu'il joue la
montre le sentiment qu'il augmente la
question la question sécuritaire prend
le pas deux on joue la montre 3 on va
refaire un débat derrière on va arriver
à la fin de l'année et ça va faire un an
que les français exigent de pouvoir
vivre correctement de leur travail de
leur retraite mais c'est se moquer du
monde
et après on va dire faut arrêter les
manifestations c'est plus possible vous
avez déjà vu un mouvement social aussi
longs qui dure comme ça sans que les
organisations politiques et syndicales
en plus soit à la manoeuvre mouvement
spontané citoyens enfin commun de
violence mais non réalisation en termes
de violence oui mais en terme de
mobilisation
on était quand même samedi dernier un
cran encore en deçà des samedi précédent
oui et je vous dirais que quand on était
plus nombreux dans la rue on n'était pas
plus entendu ça pose quand même une
question démocratique qui est posée par
ce que d'ailleurs les gilets jaunes nous
le disent
vous avez manifesté vous parti
communiste la cgt et vous n'avez pas
obtenu alors laissez-nous faire on va le
faire c'est quand même là
comment voulez vous qu après il n'y a
pas une question démocratique qui se
posent dans notre pays
hélas aujourd'hui d'ailleurs ils vont
commencer à se dire et comment il le dit
d'ailleurs atteint il faut casser pour
se faire entendre
la question à lien il faut casser pour
se faire entendre mais c'est incroyable
dans le pays il faille il faut que cette
idée là elles grandissent il va on va y
revenir tout à l'heure évidemment dans
les parties suivantes mais on arrive à
la fin des questions d'actualité et
baptiste l'écart en est une qui concerne
le parti communiste français au premier
chef
alors tout autre sujet effectivement
puisque la presse a révélé récemment des
harcèlements et agression sexuelle au
sein des jeunesses communistes
une militante a confié sur les réseaux
sociaux je sais pourquoi je suis
communiste donc c'est une militante
comme il n'y a pas de doute mais les
récentes affaires ainsi que la réaction
de mon parti m'ont choqué la réaction
mon parti elle incrimine ça aussi qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
je pense que nous sommes frappés par
une série d'agressions dans notre parti
et surtout au mouvement de la jeunesse
communiste qui sont intolérables et
inacceptables et j'ai exprimé ma colère
j'ai reçu deux de ces jeunes filles
ce dimanche pour leur dire pour leur
dire aussi que nous croyons leurs
témoignages
j'ai beaucoup rencontrer des
associations d'avocats qui qui m'ont dit
qu'ils nous ont bien dit qu'une femme
victime de viol ne ment jamais et qu'il
faut les croire
à coup sûr et vous êtes posé cette
question elle s'est posée non à les
poser en fait elle s'est posée elle est
posée par la justice parce que quand il
ya un dépôt de plainte il y à un
agresseur qui est enfin un présumé
coupable et il ya une présomption
d'innocence or il y a eu un temps cette
question qui a été posée
or nous ne sommes pas la justice il ya
un problème du côté de la justice
seulement une femme sur dix victimes de
viol va porter plainte
or nous parce que vous allez sûrement
c'est à l'issue à l'issue de ces
discussions il ya décision que nous
avons prise et que nous avons confirmé
ce week-end c'est que nous en tant que
parti si on nous ne sommes pas la
justice nous devons faire respecter les
valeurs de notre parti est chez nous il
n'y aura pas de place aucune place à ça
il y aura une exclusion prononcée sur la
base d'un témoignage d'une femme victime
d'une telle agression et nous avions mis
un tel dispositif en place
nous avions déjà mis ce dispositif en
place
mais on a montré à vue on est en train
de se rendre compte qu'il ya eu des
failles parce que quand nous avons
prononcé des exclusions nous il n'y
avait pas de procédures claires qui
étaient émises et donc un adhérent qui
étaient exclus d'une fédération on
prévenait le responsable départemental
mais on comprenait pas tous les
secrétaires départementaux et donc il a
pu revenir
par ailleurs il n'y a pas de fichier on
n'a pas le droit par exemple d'avoir un
fichier des agresseurs la loi ne le
permet pas il faudra qu'on trouve on va
il faudra qu'on trouve le moyen
juridique de se protéger des prédateurs
qui pourrait y avoir
et que et qu'on va mettre dehors c'est
un énorme chantier j'imagine douloureux
pour les victimes douloureux que des
communistes français
merci beaucoup se fit ravinel du figaro
baptiste becker d'avoir animé cette
première partie d'auditions publiques
dans un instant fabien roussel deux
parlementaires viennent de vous
interpeller à leur tour un mot pour
revenir bonsoir ou bonjour messieurs si
vous me permettez juste une petite
question qui nous arrive sur le fil
twitter du figaro et les messieurs
auditions publiques
on les appelle des anarchistes leur but
casser vandaliser la solution ne
serait-elle pas d'interdire les
manifestations dans paris en quelques
secondes et on revient avec nos invités
on ne peut pas interdire la capitale
française de toute manifestation
ça on n'a jamais vu ça donc la
manifestation pour le climat qui se
déroule correctement la manifestation
des algériens
enfin il ya eu d'autres manifestations
ce week-end qui se sont déroulées dans
le calme et tranquille mon nom c'était
pas une solution
nous accueillons martin lévriers
sénateurs la république en marge des
yvelines monsieur lévriers bon j'aurai
pierre henri dumont députée elle aime ou
pas de calais je pense que vous
connaissez vous êtes du même coin tout
cas la même région du littoral et voix
du bassin minier et c'est lui qui vous
pose la première question monsieur du
monde fabien roussel bonsoir vous aviez
évoqué en décembre dernier la volonté
d'inclure sur la liste communiste aux
élections européennes des gilet jaune
après les différents événements qui se
sont passés par exemple samedi dernier
le sac av des champs elysées le piège de
certains magasins la mise à sac de
kiosque de journaux
est-ce que vous réaffirmer leur est la
même chose aujourd'hui ils sont sur
notre liste puisqu'il y a des
ddd militants syndicaux associatifs qui
ont fait le choix d'endosser le gilet
jaune depuis des semaines depuis le
début qui sont d'ailleurs dans leur
département à la tête de ce combat qu'il
continue de mener de manière pacifique
de manière non violente et qui
continuent de porter cette revendication
de de mieux vivre avec de son travail de
sa retraite et donc ils sont aussi et
encore et toujours sur notre lycée dans
le nord pas de calais comme dans
d'autres régions de france il y a très
très grande majorité des françaises et
des français qui ont endossé un gilet
jaune manifestes ont occupé des
ronds-points le font de manière
pacifique et leurs revendications sont
légitimes et nous ne faisons pas
l'amalgamé entre cela et ceux qui
cassent savent où se cacher un mois ce
que j'estime c'est que les jets les
jeunes du 17 novembre sont bien
différents de ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
présents dans les manifestations tous
les samedis qui en effet une vraie
volonté d'avoir du pouvoir d'achat en
plus de pouvoir exprimer que une
personne qui travaille doit pouvoir
vivre dignement de son travail ce qui
n'est pas malheureusement le cas
aujourd'hui mais que continuer comme
vous venez de le faire à vouloir séparer
ceux qui viennent manifester sur les
champs-elysées qui participe de fait à
la mise à sac de la capitale pour moi ça
pose un souci et j'estime que en réalité
si vous êtes dans cette posture de
continuer à dire que les jets les jeunes
qui continuent à manifester aujourd'hui
ont toute leur place sur notre liste
cela pose un problème parce que c'est
aussi l'image de la france qui est
dégradée parce que c'est aussi les
commerces qui sont qu'ils sont en vie
mais je suis aussi il a brûlé son gilet
jaune
on parle pas des mêmes en parle pas de
la réunion le lundi c'est fini je suis
cgt sur les ronds-points et je peux vous
dire de façon extrêmement clair que
aujourd'hui 99 % des personnes de mon
territoire qui manifestaient le 17
novembre ne se reconnaissent absolument
pas dans ce qui s'est passé sur les
champs-elysées et considère au contraire
que tous les jeunes qui étaient présents
sur les champs elysées était présent
pour casser et savait pertinemment
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils venaient mais
vous savez que dans notre région de 6
millions d'habitants
vous la connaissez bien il ya un million
de personnes qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté et sur 1 millions sur 6
notre région peut être une des seules
régions qui a un taux de pauvreté aussi
élevé
il y a certains d'entre eux qui ont fait
le choix d'endosser le gilet jaune et
une grande partie d'entre eux qui ne
l'ont pas endosser mais qui n'en pensent
pas moins sûr vous savez que la colère
elle est forte elle est profonde elle
est ancrée dans notre pays elle sourde
depuis longtemps et elle explose
aujourd'hui certains ont fait le choix
de la faire exploser en portant ce gilet
jaune
beaucoup ont décidé que ce mouvement
était pacifique et moi je pense à cela
et à tous ceux qui n'ont pas le gilet
jeunes et qui demande à ce qu'on
rétablisse leur pension vous les
connaissez ce qu'ils ont perdu 30 40 50
euros par mois alors que les factures
augmentent vous savez que ça devient
insupportable
les ouvriers qui travaillent dans les
usines de chez nous il y en a encore
beaucoup dans le nord pas de calais où
les ouvriers qui travaillent poster de
nuit les week-ends gagne 1200 1300 euros
net par mois qui ne peuvent pas partir
en vacances avaient leur garage n'ont
ils pas tous raison d'exiger de se
battre de se mobiliser son réseau lors
de leur travail ils ont tort d aller en
cassant en détériorant est en effet dans
cette fois qu'on est tous d'accord sauf
sur l'idée détériorée sur la violence
crois que là-dessus vous l'avez dit
allez on est tous assez d'accord sur la
violence en revanche si vous permettez
l'évolution de ce qu'on appelle les
gilet jaune a une importance dans le
temps et il ya une prise de conscience
très forte de la reine et d'une histoire
qui date depuis 30 35 ans je crois que
si tous les politiques sont d'accord là
dessus sur cette colère qui gronde qui
monte doucement kiki qui commence à
perdurer qui est sorti violemment au
mois de novembre le gouvernement et vous
l'avez vu a réagi et a agi quand on dit
qui a pas eu de choix politiques et de
volonté politique et une volonté sociale
très forte avec la loi d'urgence sociale
que j'ai défendue au sénat d'ailleurs et
avec une robe repas non excusez-moi une
revalorisation de la prime d'activité je
parle pas de la taxe d'habitation des
bâches des jarres sociale donc un effort
sans précédent depuis des années pour
les salaires les plus bas
je dis pas que c'est suffisant vous
parlez de la nocivité de la loupe oui je
qui est donné aux ce cas ceux qui
gagnent le smic et qui vont devoir aller
chercher à la caf
le hard rock de saint louis sepalia la
cagnotte
qui vous le savez ça se fait je vous
rappel c gepa crime écrit j'ai pas fini
et je hais je vous je vous rappelle
quand même puisque j'ai vu dans vos dix
proposées en vue d'une proposition que
vous vouliez passer le smig à 1400 euros
le salaire est fait par l'entreprise
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et c'est
important et augmenter le smig c'est
augmenter indirectement tous les serres
je ne sais pas comment font les
entreprises et ma question n'était pas
là parce que je pense qu'il faut aussi
s'inquiéter de la fraternité à travers
tout ça excusez moi et j'y reviens et je
vais est assez provocateur parce que je
vais défendre quelque chose auquel je
crois et que vous n'avez qu'une envie
c'est de détruire c'est la solidarité
intergénérations intergénérationnel à
travers les retraites on n'a pas
beaucoup de possibilités pour faire
évoluer les retraites les retraites
c'est un système par répartition en
france c'est-à-dire sont les actifs
qu'ils cotisent pour les gens qui sont
déjà en retraite donc la pension que je
verse n'est pas celle qui me servira à
ma retraite malgré ce que vous dites et
ça c'est très important c'est
l'intergénérationnel donc le fait de
demander à tous les retraités dont la
pension est supérieur à 2000 euros
un effort de 1,7 pour cent pour
permettre aux actifs de cotiser moins
sur la retraite qu'ils ont à payer
moi ça me paraît une démarche très forte
est véritablement de fraternité vous
avez l'air contre et je trouve ça très
dommage j'aimerais vous m'expliquer
pourquoi vous êtes contre ben alors vous
savez la fraternité la solidarité ce qui
porte le gilet jaune l'on retrouvait sur
les ronds-points parce que beaucoup
d'entre eux vivaient seuls dans leur
coin c'est de leur colère dernier
c'est ce qu'ils nous disent le plus
souvent quand on va aller voir c'est que
dans les ronds points ils se sont soudés
retrouver et donc ils ont trouvé la
solidarité et aujourd'hui ils demandent
la fraternité et ils demandent l'égalité
c'est la crise en france on doit tous
faire des efforts et vous êtes en train
de dire les retraités peuvent faire un
effort alors pourquoi on va demander aux
retraités aux 16 millions de retraités
de faire un effort quand on fait un
cadeau aux plus riches
quand on supprime l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune sur les plus riches
comment on peut demander aux retraités
de faire un effort quand on enlève la
taxe sur les dividendes les 3% et donc
ça fait 5 milliards d'euros qu'on a
rendu aux grandes multinationales 10
milliards sur les deux dernières années
parler de solidarité quand vous faites
des cadeaux aux plus riches avec
prélèvement forfaitaire unique
exonération des taxes sur les dividendes
suppression de l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune en veux tu en voilà c'est
prêt de 12 milliards d'euros de cadeaux
qui ont été faits au capital et aux plus
riches
oui vous et vous dit mais les 16
millions de retraités peuvent payer mais
vous vous rendez compte vous croyez pas
que c'est ça que justifie surtout j'ai
l'impréssion avant il ya passé ses
entraîneurs et tous les retraités au
delà de 1000 euros vous le savez dit les
retraités peuvent payer et banny donc
c'est sacrément gonflé la solide le
riche peuvent payer
merci la solidarité atteindre seul c'est
aussi de s'écouter partage en selle et
j'ai pas dit ça je propos j'ai dit une
solidarité des jeunes dans les ag et
réciproquement
c'est pas 16 millions c'est beaucoup
moins puisque 70% sont au dessous de
2000 euros par mois donc on est à 30 %
de 16 millions déjà premiers points
deuxième point quand vous parlez de
liesse
quand vous parlez de tous ces cadeaux
entre guillemets vous savez très bien
que le monde est ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui et comment dans une économie
qui est mondialisée et vous savez aussi
bien que moi que les gens les plus
riches en france
fuyez la france pour ces raisons là je
dis pas que c'est bien et je dis que
justement il faut leur réapprendre à
retrouver la solidarité
mais ce qui s'est passé et vous l'avez
vu depuis qu'on est élu c'est que le
chômage a baissé de quasiment 1 % que le
pays est en train de se redresser
réindustrialiser pardon que les cdi sont
en remontée qui a de moins en moins de
prud'hommes donc tout ça c'est bien que
le signe que notre économie est en train
de repartir et que c'est le plus
important je rectifie juste un chiffre
députés de la commission des finances
j'ai eu les rapports sur l' isf et le
dernier convient d'avoir s'cusez moi
ceux qui ont fui la france à cause de l'
isf 0,02 pour cent sept cents exactement
exilés fils joseph dernier roulettes et
6 ans en 2016
ça va 358 ils sont 350 8000 foyers à
payer l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune et leur patrimoine total taxable
1028 milliards d'euros et c'est trop de
leur en prendre six et ben dis donc moi
je peux vous dire qu'on peut leur
rétablir lisf on peut leur rétabli
relief et il leur restera encore de quoi
venir et ce ne serait que justice
sociale et justice fiscale parce qu'avec
cet argent
oui on peut répondre aux besoins de nos
retraités notamment les maisons de
retraite les ehpad et cetera
au lieu de demander aux français comme
vous le fait de travailler une journée
de plus gratuitement alors ça oui des
efforts aux français aux salariés aux
ouvriers aux retraités vous en demander
mais là au plus riche jamais
c'est l'injustice fiscale et c'est ce
que nous combattons moi ce que je vois
c'est qu'il ya une division qui est
faite entre les français d'un côté c'est
les plus âgées qui doivent payer pour
les plus jeunes et pour monsieur roussel
c'est les plus riches qui doivent payer
pour le reste de la population
abandonnée ont parlé de leur attaquant
parler de fraternité tout à l'heure de
solidarité mon sens n'est pas forcément
comme ça que ça peut s'exercer
la principale demande de tous est de
créer de la valeur de vivre de son
travail et ça peut pas se faire en
allant taxe est celui qui est le plus
riche à côté parce que l'on aura ce sera
toujours le plus riche de quelqu'un en
espérant que ça va pouvoir de donner
plus de bénéfices la réalité c'est qu'il
faut continuer à essayer d'augmenter la
production augmenter le taux de retour à
l'emploi surtout dans la région on
partage cette cette région avec eux me
succède à d'autres élus et c'est une
c'est un territoire où il ya des gens
qui sont extrêmement volontaire et qui
malheureusement dû malartre du travail
parce qu'il ya moins d'industrie parce
que il ya de moins en moins de
possibilités et donc continuer à opposer
comme cela les français les uns aux
autres les jeunes les actifs les
retraités note fabien roussel dans ces
dix propositions c'est augmenter le smic
augmenté de 20 % augmentent et les
minima sociaux
ça va être la console favori sept sont
des recettes qui ont échoué
c'est des recettes qui viennent de
françois mitterrand elle sont pas
forcément donné un succès lui même à
l'époque j'étais jeune et donc ça ça me
montrer son atout son échec et on voit
bien que augmenter le smic ça a été dit
ça peut être illusoire mais si derrière
ça crée une inflation
si derrière ça augmente l'ensemble des
salaires et que c'est réinjecter et non
pas dans l'économie mais dans la planche
à billets c'est alors d'abord si nous
c'est pas ces pratiques ce el-arish pour
taxer les riches ça c'est pas ça c'est
la question de la solidarité justement
qui est posée jamais les plus riches
n'ont accumulé autant de richesses les
huit milliardaires français les plus
riches détiennent autant que les 30 %
les plus pauvres on n'a jamais vu ça
l'écart de salaire entre l'ouvrier et le
patio module philae de 500 alors qu'il
était de 40
il y a dix ans que le fait de ce sont
ses cendres aux huit plus grandes
on arrive à donner les sécheresses
quignard c'est pas que c'est que
aujourd'hui leçons de justice et non aux
jouets à sa ville fera que le smic à jun
azumi
il n'y a jamais eu autant de richesses
produites dans notre pays parmi tous les
salariés qui ont travaillé toute leur
vie ceux qui travaillent aujourd'hui on
n'a jamais produit autant de richesses
sauf que cette richesse
aujourd'hui elle part dans les mains
d'une infime minorité elle n'est plus
aussi bien redistribuer qu'avant c'est
ça que demandent les français
comment se fait-il qu'on demande des
efforts aux français qu'on continue
d'alléger la fiscalité sur le capital
comme nous le serine monsieur bruno le
maire toutes les semaines
alors on fait des cadeaux aux capitales
ont fait des cadeaux aux plus riches
selon la théorie du ruissellement
mais cette gare pas de robert n'y a pas
de quinn le gouverneur autoroute 30
minimes à vienne errance estimé que par
rapport aux cadeaux faits montfleury
cédait 30 euros 30 euros c'est rien le
rapport à l'électricité l'eau le
chauffage les loyers les mutuelles
boutade vous connaissez le prix des
mutuelles aujourd'hui 150 euros vous
savez bien pour une personne qui est au
smic toutes les choix budgétaires qui
ont été faits par le gouvernement actuel
arrive quasiment en un treizième mois
sur un an
avec la taxe d'habitation vous le savez
donc ça n'est pas rien pour une personne
après on pourra être 30 euros
globalement mutation messi sinon il y
avait 80 % 80 % des français paie la
taxe d'habitation donc c'est parce
qu'ils ont ce n'est maintenant pas cela
c'est les minimum est bon mais je
reprends ce que vous avez dit sur les
gens riches sur les patrons pour moi je
fais une grosse différence et je pense
qu'on pourrait se rejoindre
entre un patron celui qui crée son
entreprise qui met son argent
moi qui gagne 200 fois le smic parce
qu'il a pris tous les risques pour se
lancer dans quelque chose qui la créent
l'emploi de terre ça ne me dérange pas
en revanche en revanche pour un
directeur
un directeur un membre du comité de
direction qui est un salarié que lui
gagne 400 fois le smig
ça me pose un problème parce que quand
je parle de solidarité la giro l'année
en fait quoi et bien qu'il travaille on
travaille on pourquoi pas mais je vais
vous dire attendons aussi parce que la
magie la différence de vous j'attends
beaucoup du grand débat mais j'attends
les réponses qui vont en sortir je vais
pas proposé aujourd'hui quelque chose
j'ai des idées nous vous avez en plus
j'ai des idées
allez-y nous faisons des propositions
concrètes justement pour accompagner les
entreprises nos tpe nos pme artisans
commerçants mais aussi les hôtes et il
est plus grandes entreprises qui
investissent en france qui font le choix
de ne pas délocaliser et qui ont besoin
d'être concurrentiels et bien que le cic
eux qui a été créé pour ça leur serve à
elle ses entreprises en priorité savez
vous qu'aujourd'hui quand j'ai rencontré
la direction de google france qui a fait
de l'évasion fiscale l'accord 19,4
milliards envoyés aux bermudes
google france me dit monsieur roussel on
aimerait bien ne pas toucher le cic eux
mais il nous est versée automatiquement
et nous n'en avons pas besoin
vous trouvez ça juste vous ne pensez pas
donc ils vont bénéficier d'exonérations
de charges qu'il nous manque et l'emploi
derrière cette l'emploi merci n'entre
pas besoin vous allez versée vous allez
faire bénéficier d'exonérations de
cotisations sociales des salariés
d'entreprises qui n'en n'ont pas besoin
google nous dit nous n'avons pas besoin
du cic eux
pourquoi on nous le vert ce
automatiquement violents eh bien ils ont
il faudrait à la place que ceux ci se
soient versées aux entreprises qui en
ont besoin et leur permettre ainsi
d'augmenter les salaires de payer des
cotisations qui servent à financer la
protection sociale la santé notre
système de retraites aujourd'hui avec
vos système d'exonération jusqu'à 2000
euros quasiment les salariés ne paieront
plus les employeurs ne paieront plus de
cotisations sociales
alors qu'est ce qu'on va nous sortir
après quand tu auras toujours la crise
parce que ça ne va pas améliorer la
situation de l'emploi schwaller que ces
entreprises aujourd'hui les pme elles
ont besoin d'activités elles ont besoin
de travailler de commandes c'est bien
pour ça que nous nous disons relance ont
le pouvoir d'achat relance ont la
consommation pour que cela fasse tourner
nos entreprises quels services et
qu'elle travaille en france
c'est montparnasse motion si vous voulez
bien fabien roussel
une autre question différente mais
extrêmement importante aussi pour
l'avenir de la nation française la
cohésion
pierre-henri vivement andré gérin qui
était ancien député maire de vénissieux
communiste qui appartenait au groupe
auquel vous appartenez vous à partir
d'aujourd'hui était un des instigateurs
de la loi sur l'interdiction du port du
voile intégral
elle avait fait une mener une mission
parlementaire sur le sujet et dans les
derniers événements nous avons pu
constater que ce soit avec etam avec
décathlon
nous avons assez peu entendu la voix du
parti communiste français sur ces
histoires alors est ce que aujourd'hui
le parti communiste français dont vous
êtes le secrétaire national serait
capable de pouvoir prendre des mesures
aussi forte qu il a pu le faire quand
andré gerin sont occupés à l'assemblée
nationale bon c'est parce que vous nous
lisez pas ou bien vous n'écoutez pas
mais nous nous sommes exprimés je me
suis exprimé sur ce sujet et quand j'ai
vu le l'ampleur que ça a pris l'histoire
de décathlon qui vont des hidjabs au
running pour les jeunes femmes y en a
qui sont étaient faire du sport je me
suis dit mais c'est pas possible mais
notre pays est il tombé si bas pour
faire des polémiques sur des sujets
comme ça voyez vous moi je trouve que
parfois on a le le don d'hystériser sur
des sujets et de passer à côté d'autres
plus importants il me préoccupe plus moi
de savoir donc penser qu'il est bien jeu
comme un pierrot et du mans je mets à
votre réponse vous à jouer mais je me
d'abord je me préoccupe plus de ce que
les jeunes femmes ont dans la tête que
sur la tête
d'abord et je suis pour une république
laïque qui permet à chacun de d'exercer
sa foi librement plutôt qu'une
république qui interdit qui règlement
comme ça se fait d'ailleurs dans des
pays qui ne sont pas démocratiques et
qui eux qu'on connaît heureusement eu
internet
ça veut dire ça veut dire que vous
estimez que des cats ont parfaitement le
droit jeu de
pouvoir vendre ses îles devrait
continuer aujourd'hui la loi les lois
qui existent et notamment la loi sur la
laïcité la loi de 1905 les lois de la
république française sont bel et bien
fait ce qui manque ce sont des calmants
fasse de l'argent sur une revendication
communautaire waouh je poissy décathlon
son objectif c'est faire de l'argent il
ya beaucoup d'argent dans ces le groupe
mulliez
donc il s'en sort après je sais pas pour
l'instant c'est pas les entreprises
c'est pas seulement elles ne vendent pas
pendant elles répondent en fait un
besoin et si c'est pas des cas de plomb
qui le vend elles trouveront ccc à faire
ailleurs sur internet ou en belgique
puisque nous on est à côté de la
frontière belge et donc on répond pas au
problème
enfin c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet
c'est pourquoi il ya de plus en plus de
communautarisme dans notre pays la
communauté we de communes de l'arize
non voyez ça là on va être d'accord là
dessus lors comment on fait pour faire
en sorte que dans notre pays il est
moins de communautarisme d'ailleurs
pourquoi la même minute
ah bah pour moi une commune de taille
puisque vous appuyez moindre
communautaire est bien plus de
république plus libéré cet abattoir en
une minute je vais pas sortir mais qui
saura si ce sera pas une mesure
d'interdiction jeu mais ce sera une
république qui fait vivre tous ses
droits
véritablement liberté égalité fraternité
et quand je dis qu'il faut plus
s'occuper il faut plus se préoccuper de
ce qu'il ya dans les têtes que sur la
tête
effectivement la question de l'école de
l'accès à la connaissance à la culture
de permettre à nos communes à noville
d'avoir les moyens de faire vivre tout
le monde dans le donne dans de manière
égalitaire aujourd'hui ce n'est plus ça
aujourd'hui on supprime des services
publics dans les quartiers dans les
banlieues mais aussi nos villages ont de
la peine à joindre les deux bouts
et donc on est dans une république qui
exclut par tous les bouts et bien il y à
des communautés qui se resserre entre
elle et c'est pas la solution il ya une
république qui exclut par tous les bouts
nous dit fabien celle merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous martin lévriers et
pierre-henri du mans merci infiniment
d'avoir à votre tour animer ce débat et
dans un instant la dernière partie avec
nos deux journalistes de l'ocp et public
sénat
[Musique]
voilà le débat avait tendance à se
poursuivre pendant le vine galère face
de vous au rayonnement fini de public
sénat et brigitte boucher de lcp l'avant
soir mesdames on va d'abord s'arrêter si
vous voulez bien sur votre stratégie
pour les élections européennes du 26 mai
vous avez décidé d'y aller seul vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi
seul louis le parti communiste sans
alliance mais si on sait quand vous
regardez les sondages pardon des prix
mais pas un peu vous stagné à 2 % vous
êtes vraiment en bas bon
je regrettais pas justement cette
solitude marre des choses que j'ai la
tête de déprimer c'est ça non mais
peut-être que vous cachez votre jeu pour
nous mais nous pensons d'abord vous
dites que nous sommes seuls c'est pas
sympa on est la seule liste d'où son nom
nous sommes la seule liste composée 50 %
d'ouvriers de salariés qui ne sont pas
tous car tu es au parti communiste
français qui portent des combats dans
leur entreprise dans là où ils sont
engagés dans leur association dans leurs
villages dans leur quartier et donc nous
sommes l'apple la seule liste à l'image
de la france qui travaille et nous
sommes la seule le seul parti politique
qui depuis 79 soit la question des
traités européens avant toujours été
clair nous sommes le seul parti de
gauche à avoir dénoncé ces traités
européens ultra libéraux qui ont fait
tant de mal et à la france et à l'europe
parce que si l'europe est dans cet état
aujourd'hui si il ya une telle montée
des populismes s'il ya 87 millions de
personnes sous le seuil de pauvreté en
europe et 9 millions en france oui ces
traités européens sont une grande
responsabilité et nous à gauche le parti
communiste français à gauche depuis
georges marchais en 79 jusqu'à ian
brossât en 2019
eh bien nous sommes cohérents là dessus
une authenticité qui peine à convaincre
on va essayer de comprendre pourquoi on
vient d'en finir il vous est cohérent
mais ce n'est pas vraiment le même score
qu'à l'époque florissante du parti
communiste est ce que du coup votre
stratégie d'y aller c'est alors vous
n'êtes pas seul ce prime vous êtes le
seul parti en tout cas vous ne vous êtes
pas lié avec d'autres parties est ce que
ce n'est pas suicidaire pour le parti
communiste
mais d'abord la question des alliances
elle se pose quand nous sommes d'accord
pour défendre au moins le même menu le
même programme
même idée et qu'on est d'accord là
dessus il ya un sujet sur lequel nous ne
dévierons pas c'est la question des
traités européens nous voulons remous
mais remettons en cause ces traités
européens nous ne changerons pas
l'europe à traiter constant donc à
gauche ça veut dire quoi mais à gauche
qu aux baladeurs voulait
était constitutionnelle que les français
ont rejeté en 2005 par la grande porte
et que monsieur sarkozy et monsieur
hollande ont fait rentrer par la fenêtre
c'est rester là nous mais je reviens sur
l'idée que nous sommes à 2 % 3 % 4 % et
donc ce serait très difficile mais
voyez-vous hanicotte on a esté
effectivement peut-être absents des
derniers grands rendez vous électoraux
nationaux
le parti communiste est peut-être
d'ailleurs c'est vous les journalistes
souvent qui nous l'avait dit vous êtes
sorti des écrans radars de la politique
eh bien nous rentrons dans les écrans
radars dont et bien c'est le délire is
back
comme je le dit et maintenant c'est la
remontée tadam mais sur un bon jour là
la france insoumise propose la même
chose que vous finalement sortait des
traités ils sont stupides a dit jean luc
mélenchon il l'a même écrit dans une
tribune
alors pourquoi vous vous alliez pas la
france insoumise et bien parce que
peut-être il y a kylie a entre nous des
différences beaucoup de points communs
nous concerne nous nous rejetons tous
les deux nos deux forces politiques
ces traités européens nous n'avons pas
forcément la même vision de les
combattre et de de sortir de ces traités
européens
jean luc mélenchon et sa formation
politique ont théorisé l'idée que
l'europe on les aime ou on la quitte
le plan à si ça marche ça marche si ça
n'a pas loupé dit et nous sort nous
mettons en avant nous l'idée que cette
europe
eh bien nous croyons nous au fait qu' il
y à des combats que nous devons mener à
l'échelle de l'union européenne la
question environnementale climatique
nous sommes favorables à ce qu'il y ait
des services publics européens qui
fonctionne ce combat là nous voulons
mener
eh bien pas du tout l'impression que la
pensée insoumise me tuer
le pc comme elle veut tuer le ps est ce
que c'est pas ça qui vous fait peur non
mais je fais répondre précisément à
votre question nous pensons nous qu'il y
a des rapports de force à jouer au sein
de l'union européenne et notamment au
sein la force d'un groupe politique qui
je le souhaite deviendrait majoritaire
pour porter un contenu progressiste à
cette europe et donc
retrouvons nous au sein d'un groupe
politique au sein de l'union européenne
à venir avec des députés insoumis et
avec d'autres pourquoi pas mais pour
répondre précisément à votre question
nous pensons que la france est soumise
avec sa stratégie sa vision de la
transformation de la société du rapport
de force
ils sont sur l'idée que nous ils disent
les clés les insoumis c'est le peuple
contre les élites
quand nous nous disons il faut défendre
les valeurs de gauche et savoir les
rassembler contre les politiques menées
par la droite ce sont deux stratégies
complètement différente
la france a soumise à son électorat il
parle à son électorat
le parti communiste doit reconquérir son
électorat et notre souhait c'est de nous
additionner demain c'est de faire en
sorte que dans un groupe qu'il aimait
qui la questionnait mais ça veut dire
que demain ça veut dire que demain je
souhaite à ce que la france insoumise
fasse élire le plus d'élus possible
qu'on pour combattre ces traités et que
nous aussi nous le fassions je pense que
si nous étions dans une même liste
nous n'aurions pas nous ne ferions pas
le même score et voyez-vous la gauche
aujourd'hui elle fait 25%
quand on additionne tous les vacances
vous pensez que si on se mettait tous
ensemble ça fera encore 25%
je pense que c'est ccc stratégie là sont
justement celles que les gens de gauche
ne veulent plus il faut que chacun on
reconstruit ça complique quand même le
soin des commentaires d'avoir autant de
lise jolly ce sera fini il entend de
listes à droite marie vaton mais c'est
la goutte de sang dupont aignan dlr et
cetera non mais chacun à la raison n'est
pas raison à leurs noms mais avait
choisi un blâme et la gauche à chaque
fois il y a toujours eu à gauche une
valeur dans l'histoire regarder depuis
il ya toujours eu une liste du parti
communiste une liste du parti socialiste
est à la limite c'était tous les
écologistes avant était avec les
socialismes jean luc mélenchon était
avant avec les socialistes et donc il ya
un parti le parti socialiste qui s'est
beaucoup éclaté dans les parties
communes pour le pour le compte on est
là depuis le début
et on est encore là on devine donc
sépare nous qu'il faut parler de la
division a dressé sa cette remarque aux
autres mais prague
alors on va parler du parti socialiste
claudy effort n'a pas choisi la même
stratégie cloud vous pour la revenante
ada vous vous dites qu'il faut liste
autonome lille a choisi de s'effacer
pour faire renaître le parti socialiste
c'est donc raphaël glucksmann de place
publique qui va conduire la liste du
parti socialiste qu'est ce qu'on y
pensait peut-être stratégie ou là là
mais moi je ne vais pas me permettre de
commenter les choix de mes camarades
aussi est-ce que vous à un moment il a
été question vous allez à ce public
trouvez que c'est une bonne écoute et
j'ai répondu nous avons répondu à à ce
que la proposition que faisait place
publique mais qui ne répondait pas dans
leur je crois une dizaine de
propositions il n'y avait rien sur
l'otan y avait rien sur les traités
européens et l'idée de les remettre en
cause y compris de se retrouver ensemble
dans un groupe qui combat demain ces
traités européens alors qu'on doit
constituer une force importante
ben oui mais donc à partir du moment
vous savez pour que la gauche la gauche
voyez ça comme un meuble avec dans un
meuble un meuble est composé de
plusieurs sortes de bois il ya du bois
dur et du bois tanguay d'ubs revers il
ya du moyeu tic
il ya un bel parti communiste et le soft
c'est la base il ya besoin que la gauche
retrouve une colonne vertébrale solide
non pas derrière
si demain on trouve sur un câble et non
même par exemple je tends encore la main
je leur fais ce soir à benoît hamon avec
qui nous partageons beaucoup de points
communs il peut encore s'il vient alors
que 70% des français 10 des électeurs de
gauche et écologistes des électeurs
pardon de gauche et écologistes disent
que c'est une bonne idée vous avez
refusé cette votation pourquoi pas mais
parce que c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe c'est bon c'est pas par des
votations comme ça ça a été une infime
nombre d'électeurs de
les militants dénoncent non les nôtres
ont dit les électeurs les militants du
parti communiste français ont dit le
parti communiste français a toujours été
constant sur les traités européens
c'est une élection certes difficile pour
nous mais sur laquelle nous avons et
donc il n'y croit et donc bien mais
j'invite toujours benoît hamon à ce que
l'on se retrouve et à ce que l'on se
mette d'accord avec ian brossât comme
tête de liste
c'est une cuisine nombreux ça non c'est
une question de cohérence politique
parce que justement benoît hamon fait le
choix de se distinguer du parti
socialiste sur le fond pas pour d'autres
raisons sur le fond et c'est justement
ce que je lui dis la garantie de montils
adil doit choisir aujourd'hui où il va
tout seul avec les risques que ça
comporte où il va avec
glucksmann qui a voté qui a appelé à
voter pour monsieur sarkozy piper
monsieur mac rompuy qui maintenant va
tirer de liste du parti socialiste c'est
le choix des électeurs socialistes et
benoît monde aller avec eux ou de venir
avec nous sur une liste ouvert large
rassembleuse sur laquelle on ce qu'on
pourra dire ensemble l'europe que nous
voulons construire une europe
progressiste vous avez eu un contact
avec fait récemment part me rassure on
se parle régulièrement pour tous les
jours mais on ne sait pas une question
de congrès c'est ben voilà pour
l'instant et 10 à moi je la vis encore
et je dis que nous sommes toujours
ouverts au rassemblement réellement en
attendant est ce que ces divisions à
gauche puisqu'il ya division ne
contribue pas faire de cette élection un
duel emmanuel macron marine le pen alors
division à gauche et à droite puisque il
y aura une quinzaine de liste aux
élections européennes c'est pas 15
disent de gauche donc la droite avec les
responsables de droite toute la
responsabilité sur le dos pour pas
pousser quand même emmanuel macron joue
un jeu dangereux mais c'est la même
stratégie que sur les violences
avec les gilet jaune il faut c'est
marrant c'est comme s'il lui fallait un
ennemi sur qui taper eon et puis en
dehors de ça on ne parle plus de rien il
a décidé que c'était le chevalier blanc
face à l'extrême droite face à marine le
pen et donc les français auraient le
choix entre le libéralisme à la sauce
macron où le libéralisme d'extrême
droite marine le pen a mis en cause
l'arrivée plus aujourd'hui à séduire des
électeurs
nous disons que nous la gauche est mal
en france en europe en espagne portrait
dans plein de pays
aujourd'hui c'est l'extrême droite qui
monte
ça devrait tous nous inquiéter et nous
poser la question pour quelle raison
c'est de la faute à nous qui avons
dénoncé cette sait traiter cette
construction européenne qui produit tant
de pauvreté de délocalisation de souffle
et on est content que les électeurs
selon la banque que l'on ne soit pas
audible et que l'on ne suscite pas
l'espoir c'est un sujet c'est un vrai
sujet puisque tous les jours dit il
c'est notre faute c'est l'année de
l'espoir aux abstentionnistes moite et
aux absentionnistes que je veux parler
je veux pas piquer des voix à la france
un soumise ni au parti socialiste c'est
pour ça que c'est je respecte les choix
qui sont faits par les uns et par les
autres
en revanche nous avons chacun la mission
d'aller reconquérir notre électorat pour
que la gauche demain ne fasse pas 25%
mais en face cinquante cinq pour
redonner un pays n'arrange pas pu
réembaucher et ben oui et on voit que ça
conduit un essai de boucher on va passer
à d'autres sujets d'actualité mais
d'abord une petite question vous avez
gagné votre bras de fer avec france 2 ou
pas est-ce que vous serez présent par
ian brossât interposés le soir du 4
avril dans la grande émission qui reçoit
toutes les têtes de listes européennes
oui dans donc le ramdam a eu du bon
c'est presque toutes les raisons que
l'on vient d'évoquer
notre place était parmi les autres têtes
de liste en revanche bfm fin fait une
réunion avec six chefs de partis qui ont
participé enfin sur le grand débat ils
issus de grands des voix et il n'habite
pas la seule force politique
d'opposition qui a organisé des débats
distribuer des cahiers de doléances
déposé dix propositions à savoir moi je
leur dis qu'ils charrient voilà organes
mancini mais sur la prochaine élection
les municipales est ce que là aussi vous
serez sur une ligne d'autonomie est ce
que vous aurez des candidats partout est
ce qu'il y aura des alliances alors les
élections municipales c'est quand même 4
presque 36000 communes en france et 33
mille de moins de 3500 habitants dans
les villages dans les communes on parle
pas d'alliance avec machin pathak
l'élection municipale
c'est l'élection reine où on construit
les rassemblements les plus proches des
gens des listes citoyenne où on part des
préoccupations locales pas des appareils
politiques et donc le parti communiste
participera partout à des listes avec
d'autres forces politiques quand il y en
a ou sans force politique et avec les
habitants d'une ville d'un village sur
la base d'un programme construit avec
eux à la base et non et bien sûr en fin
mai et avec des mes camarades a soumis
ou avec nos amis écologistes
sur le fond on arrive à créer un
rassemblement qui répond à un appel des
habitants qu'ils veulent dans une
commune en ont marre du maire qui a rien
fait sur la petite enfance la garderie
les services publics la propreté ou des
choses comme ça et bien rassemblons nous
rassemblons nous y compris les coins ce
qu'ils ont dans la majorité les canniers
d'albums mais alors je conviens avec
vous que peut-être que sur les grandes
villes le sujet se pose autrement et que
là effectivement les les
discussion autres forces politiques se
posent elles vont avoir lieu
elles ont lieu actuellement gouvernée à
baigneurs et gagny d'albums ignorait qu
il n'y a rien et c'est celle décidée à
ce jour mais pour côtoyer beaucoup ian
brossât qui est adjoint
je remarque que quand la gauche est unie
et qu'elle fait un travail on respecte
chacune des forces on peut faire du beau
travail et les élus communistes qui ont
été élus dans une liste d'union ont fait
et font un bon travail à paris votre
état d'esprit à ce stade
brigitte boucher encore deux questions
d'actualité rapidement d'avoir le sénat
oui le sénat qui se réunit jeudi pour
décider ou non de saisir le parquet
après la commission d' enquête sur la
sphère benalla que doit-il faire selon
vous je trouve que le sénat a fait un
travail remarquable
vive le sénat vive la diversité au sénat
mais non mais la nation mais bien sûr
enfin surtout en un groupe au sénat
on ne regroupe aussi bien des sénateurs
communistes on va pas leur couper la
tête utiles sur la cantonale assure
vincent kra et sur les trois conseillers
du président de la république
mais bien sûr il faut aller au bout de
sept ans continue encore des zones
d'ombré et s'il n'y avait non mais quand
je dis bravo le sénat c'est parce que le
sénat contrairement à l'assemblée
nationale où nous sommes submergés par
la majorité absolue aux marges qui ne
nous permet pas d'avoir des discussions
sereines au sénat en revanche la
diversité politique qui existe à fait
qu'ils ont une commission denquête où
tous les groupes politiques ont pu
participer et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
réussi à faire ce travail est là quand
on a voulu le faire à l'assemblée
nationale la majorité en marche
ils ont tous vers vous dis à fait réglé
et non qu'on ne peut pas discuter
le sénat sert c'est une chambre
particulière parce qu'avec ces élus sont
élus par les élus mais en plus elle joue
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui un rôle
donc dernière question à voir ce que
valent puisque vous êtes député du nord
la syrie d'ascq ovale en sursis décision
de justice la semaine prochaine le 27
mars
bruno le maire dit avoir des repreneurs
sérieux est ce que vous croyez en sa
parole
un blanc à l'antenne oui oui parce que
je sais qu'il ya des repreneurs sérieux
mais là n'est pas le sujet parce qu'il y
avait déjà un repreneur sérieux avant
hâtif a oui oui oui je vous le dis il y
avait un repreneur sérieux le problème
d'altidore et le problème des repreneurs
qui vont se poser et c'est ça qu'il va
falloir regarder il y aura t-il à côté
du repreneur
une banque qui va jouer son rôle de
banque c'est-à-dire d'accompagner un
chef d'entreprise dans le risque qui
peut prendre à quoi servent les banques
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une banque qui
est là à côté d'un repreneur altis fort
n'avait pas de banque il a dû à faire
appel un fonds d'investissement un fonds
de titrisation
excusez moi le nom espagnol dont le
siège est à luxembourg qui a fait une
lettre d'intention comme quoi il allait
mettre 25 millions d'euros sur la table
et au dernier moment ils n'ont pu aller
sous une banque ne ferait jamais ça les
banques doivent jouer leur rôle et leur
rôle c'est de financer l'économie aux
côtés des chefs d'entreprise sa députée
communiste qui va ici défendre les chefs
d'entreprise pour que les banques jouent
le rôle pendant toutes mes lancers mais
oui mais scénario les bons mais j'étais
serein et cali fort et ça n'a pas marché
donc je serai je serai vigilant vigilant
parce qu'il y à des repreneurs l'état
nous doit confirmer son engagement mais
doit surtout obtenir que les banques
participent
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons de nationaliser une grande
banque privée
comme ça au moins on aura une banque qui
fera sombre société générale ou bnp je
voulais choisir mais enfin l'une des
deux fera la faire merci beaucoup avoue
roger boucher de lcp oriane mancini de
public c'est là vous serez candidat
présidentiel en 2022 mais en 2010
dire désormais les messages et ça se
trouve peut-être que on sait pas merci
un peu du fier d'ars du feu raymond
devos est en tout cas ça fait
rafraîchissant merci beaucoup à vous
d'avoir suivi audition publique michel
grossiord revient bien sûr la semaine
prochaine l'invité sera le président du
groupe et l'air bruno retailleau bonne
semaine à tous merci encore fabien
roussel rappelé
[Musique]